ATTENDANCE ARCHULETA AT KINS
BABIES BACKER FORGES BRADFORD
CUT BY ADAM CORTEZ C. DALLEY
DIED THE RUSSELL EGGMAN GLAZER
GONZALES GROWTH HERZBERG WEST
SO FURTADO JONES CAN LONGER
pMELINDA'S MAN NEWMAN NIELSEN A
SHOW OF VOGUE PAN FORTINO ROTH
RUBIO SKINNER STERN AMBERG BY
CAL SKI WINNER WILKE. THANK YOU
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN A QUORUM
IS PRESENT WITH THE MEMBERS AND
OUR GUESTS BEYOND THE RAIL AND
THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE WILL BE
LED IN PRAYER THIS AFTERNOON BY
SENATOR CAFIERO AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING WILL BE
LED IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG BY SENATOR WIENER.
SERICA THERE. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT. PEOPLE WALKED
THROUGH MY PRAYERS AND I NEVER
NOTICED INTENT ON MY OWN
AFFAIRS. PEOPLE WALK THROUGH MY
PRAYERS AND I SAW THEM
INTRUSIVE DISRUPTING
DISTRACTING. NOW PEOPLE WALK
THROUGH MY PRAYERS AND I
INCLUDE THEM CARING GIVING
BLESSING. PEOPLE WALK THROUGH
MY PRAYERS AND CHANGE ME
SOMETIMES DISTURBING DEMANDING
ENLARGING. PEOPLE WALK THROUGH
MY PRAYERS AND EMBRACE ME
HEALING LOVING FORGIVING.
PEOPLE WALK THROUGH MY PRAYERS
BEARING THE CHRIST TRANSFORMING
ME. LOVING GOD HELP US TO LOOK
DEEPLY INTO THE HEARTS OF THOSE
WHO WALK THROUGH OUR PRAYERS SO
THAT WE MAY KNOW OUR
INTERCONNECTEDNESS WITH ONE
ANOTHER. AMEN. CALLS PLEASE
JOIN ME IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE.
SIX THANK YOU SENATORS. FOR THE
OPENING PRAYER AND PLEDGE.
MEMBERS OF WE CAN ALL JUST HANG
TIGHT FOR A BIT WE'RE GOING TO
GET SOME- UNDERWAY ON BUSINESS
HERE PRETTY SOON.
MEMBERS
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL MOVE
TO CONSIDERATION OF THE BUDGET
BILL. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ THE COMMITTEE REPORT
SUBMITTED BY THE BUDGET IN
FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE. MR
PRESIDENT THE COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW TO
WHICH WAS REFERRED ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE TWENTY EIGHT REPORTS
THE SAME BACK WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION DO PASSIVE NANCY
SKINNER CHAIR ABOVE BILL
ORDERED TO SECOND READING.
THANK YOU MA'AM SECRETARY-
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS SENATORS
SCANNER FOR WHAT PURPOSE DO YOU
RIGHT. NOW SINISTER NO NOT DONE
JUST WAIT UNTIL YOU'RE READY.
OKAY SO. SIX PARTIES FIGHTING-
MOVING TO SUSPEND THE SENATE
RULES IN ORDER TO TAKE UP
EIGHTY ONE TWENTY EIGHT THANK
YOU SENATOR SKINNER. SEEING NO
OBJECTION YOU MAY PROCEED. IS
THE SAYING NO OBJECTION THE
SENATE RULES ARE SUSPENDED
CENTRE SCANNER YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU. REMEMBERS THE I'M
SORRY I'M SORRY SIR- SCANNER
YEAH- I STRUCTURE HIM PLEASE
RETURN YES. A FAMILY BILL ONE
TWENTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
TANG AN ACT RELATING TO THE
STATE BUDGET TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BUDGET BELL.
CENTERS SKINNER THANK YOU
MEMBERS EIGHTY ONE TWENTY EIGHT
IS THE BUDGET BILL FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
FISCAL YEAR. AND IT IS THE
RESULT OF A LOT OF HARD WORK
SINCE JANUARY I THINK- THOSE OF
YOU WHO ARE ON THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE OR WHO MAY HAVE
OBSERVED SOME OF THE BUDGET
HEARINGS. THEY HAVE BEEN-
THOROUGH THERE BEEN MANY
STAKEHOLDERS AND PUBLIC
INVOLVED VETTING PROPOSALS AND
OF COURSE- INTRODUCING
PROPOSALS SO REALLY WANT TO
GIVE MY APPRECIATION TO THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
STAFF AND OF COURSE ALL OF YOU
WHO ALSO. GIVE YOUR INPUT IN
THIS AND OF COURSE THE PUBLIC.
WITH THE DECADE OF RESPONSIBLE
BUDGET ACTIONS BY THE
LEGISLATURE THEREOF IS STUCK IN
THE PUBLIC BENEFITS DEVILISH
VARIOUS RESERVES AND OTHER
ACTIONS ALONG WITH ROBUST
FEDERAL STIMULUS CALIFORNIA WAS
ABLE TO WEATHER THE COVERT
NINETEEN CRISIS WITHOUT MAKING.
BUDGET CUTS AND YOU CAN RECALL
LAST YEAR WE THOUGHT THAT THERE
WAS GOING TO BE A SIGNIFICANT
DROP IN REVENUES AND SO WE
PREPARED AND WE PUT WE MADE
SOME CUTS WE PUT IN SOME A
TRUCKER CATCH BUT WE WERE NOT.
WE WERE NOT REQUIRED TO HAVE TO
FOLLOW THROUGH WITH THOSE AND
SO THOSE ARE RESTORED IN THIS
BUDGET AND HAVE BEEN IN SOME
CASES OVER THE COURSE OF OUR
EARLY ACTIONS. BUT WHAT WE FACE
TODAY IS THAT WE ARE IN AN
UNPRECEDENTED POSITION TO MAKE
TRANSFORMATIVE INVESTMENTS. AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS BUDGET BILL
DOES IT IS A BUDGET BASED ON
THE L. E. O.'S REVENUES WHICH
AS WE HEARD THIS MORNING IN
COMMITTEE. INCORPORATE REVENUES
THAT HAVE COME IN THAT CAME IN
TOO LATE TO BE INCORPORATED
INTO THE MAY REVISE. EIGHTY ONE
TWENTY EIGHT INCLUDES MUCH OF
THE ADMINISTRATION'S MAY REVISE
PROPOSALS ALONG WITH PRIORITIES
OF THE LEGISLATURE TO MAKE
TRANSFORMATIVE INVESTMENTS AS I
MENTIONED THAT WILL IMPROVE THE
LIVES OF ALL CALIFORNIANS.
WINDOWS INCLUDES. INCREASING
THE NUMBER OF PLACEMENTS FOR
CHILD FOR CHILDREN WHO NEED
CHILDCARE. BY TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND AS WELL AS ONE POINT
ONE BILLION TO IMPLEMENT
CHILDCARE RATE REFORM WHICH
MEANS TO PAY OUR CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS BETTER THAN THOSE OF
US WHO WATCH THIS PANDEMIC KNOW
THAT MANY MORE WOMEN LEFT THE
WORKPLACE AND WHY BECAUSE OF
COURSE IN THE CLOSURES THEY HAD
NO WORD THEY COULD BRING. THE
PEOPLE THAT WERE DEPENDENT ON
THEM THAT OTHERWISE WERE CARED
FOR BY EITHER CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS OR SOMEONE ELSE WHEN-
EVERYTHING BEFORE PANDEMIC AND
SO WHAT HAPPENS WOMEN END UP
STAYING HOME AND OF COURSE WE
KNOW THAT'S THE CASE EVEN WHEN
IT'S- NOT CHILD CARE THAT IS
THE PROBLEM BUT ANY OTHER CARE.
THAT WE DEPEND ON SOMEONE ELSE
TO PROVIDE FOR OUR FAMILY
MEMBERS WHO NEED IT SO THIS
TRANSFORMATIVE INVESTMENT OF
CHILD CARE AND OTHERS THAT I
WILL. DESCRIBED IN A MOMENT.
WITH SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVED
WHEN THE LIVES OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS BUT ESPECIALLY
FAMILIES AND WOMEN. THEY'RE ALL
THROUGH REALLY IMPRESSIVE
FINANCIAL AID REFORMS INCLUDING
THE BIGGEST CAL GRANTS
EXPANSION SINCE ITS INCEPTION
AND REBOOTING OF THE MIDDLE
CLASS SCHOLARSHIP TO COVER NON
TUITION COSTS FOR STUDENTS. AND
THESE TRANSFORMATIVE
INVESTMENTS WILL HELP
CALIFORNIANS PURSUE THEIR
HIGHER EDUCATION DREAMS IN A
WAY THAT RESULTS IN THEM OT
HAVING TO BE CRIPPLED WITH
STUDENT DEBT. WE'VE EXPANDED
MEDI CAL ELIGIBILITY TO ALL
INCOME ELIGIBLE CALIFORNIANS
FIFTY PLUS YEARS OF AGE
REGARDLESS OF THEIR STATUS
BECAUSE THAT IS THE RIGHT THING
TO DO. WE ARE RESTORING TWO
THIRDS OF WHAT REMAINS OF THE
CUTS THAT WE HAD TO MAKE IN
THAT DEEP DARKEST RECESSION. S.
S. I. N. S. S. P. AND THESE ARE
MONTHLY PAYMENTS THAT ARE THE
LIFELINE MANY CALIFORNIANS
DEPEND ON. WE ARE ALSO PHASING
IN THE INCREASES TO THE
PROVIDERS WHAT THEY'RE PAID WHO
PROVIDE THE DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES AND SO WHAT THAT'S
CALLED IS THE DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES PROVIDER RATE STUDY.
BUT THOSE FOLKS HAVE NOT HAD
THEIR RATES FULLY RESTORED
AGAIN SINCE THAT RECESSION AND
SO WE ARE BEGINNING TO ADDRESS
THAT NOT BEGINNING BUT WE HAVE
PUT IT ON A PATH TO RESOLVE IT
AND TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE
PAID ADEQUATELY AND THE PEOPLE
DEPENDED ON THEM. ARE ABLE TO
HAVE THEIR NEEDS MET. WE ALSO
REMOVED THE PART WE ARE.
RESTORING PERMANENTLY THE CARD
STORE IN HOME SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES HOURS. WE'VE MADE
IMPROVEMENTS TO CAL WORKS
PROGRAM TO BETTER SERVE OUR
ECONOMICALLY STRUGGLING
FAMILIES WE ARE PROVIDING STATE
FUNDED NUTRITION BENEFITS TO
CALIFORNIANS. WHO ARE IN
ELIGIBLE FOR EITHER CALFRESH OR
THE FOOD ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS
SOLELY DUE TO THEIR IMMIGRATION
STATUS. AND TO ADDRESS THE
CRISIS THAT WE SEE EACH AND
EVERYONE OF US EVERY DAY WITH
SO MANY OF OUR NEIGHBORS ON
HOUSE AND LIVING IN ENCAMPMENTS
ON OUR STREETS OR PARKS OR
ELSEWHERE AB ONE TWENTY EIGHT
PROVIDES EIGHT POINT FIVE
BILLION IN NEW FUNDING FOR
HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS. OVER THE
NEXT TWO YEARS INCLUDING ONE
BILLION IN ONGOING FLEXIBLE
LOCAL FUNDING. IN RECOGNIZING
THAT A FINE OR A FEE TO A
PERSON OR A FAMILY WHOSE INCOME
IS BARELY ALREADY MAKING ENDS
MEET CAN BE GIVEN THE DEATH
SPIRAL THAT ENDS PERHAPS IN
THEIR LOSING YOUR CAR. WHICH IS
THEN THEIR TRANSPORTATION TO
WORK SO LOSING A JOB
POTENTIALLY OR EVEN A HOME.
EIGHTY ONE TWENTY EIGHT
ELIMINATES VARIOUS CRIMINAL
ADMINISTRATIVE FEES. PORTER
SMALL BUSINESSES IN OUR
NONPROFIT SO THAT HE CAN GET
FULLY BACK ON THEIR FEET.
THERE'S ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
IN ADDITIONAL SMALL BUSINESS
AND NONPROFIT GRANTS. THEY'RE
ALSO HISTORIC. INVESTMENTS IN
RESOURCES IN INFRASTRUCTURE
PACKAGES IN SUCH THINGS AS
DROUGHT WILDFIRE CLIMATE
RESILIENCY AND MORE. AND
THERE'S EIGHT POINT ONE BILLION
AND ANOTHER ROUND OF GOLDEN
STATE STIMULUS PAYMENTS AND
MUCH MUCH MORE. ALL OF THIS. IS
WHY WE CONTINUE OUR RESPONSIBLE
BUDGETING PRACTICES WITH TWENTY
FIVE POINT FIVE BILLION IN OUR
TOTAL RESERVES. PAYING OFF
FULLY THE EDUCATION DEFERRALS
AND MAKING ADVANCE PAYMENTS ON
SOME BOND DEBTS. THE BUDGET WE
ARE PASSING TODAY REPRESENTS A
TWO PARTY DEAL BETWEEN THE
SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY THIS IS
THE LEGISLATURE'S BUDGET. WE
ARE WORKING HARD TO OBTAIN A
THREE PARTY DEAL THAT INCLUDES
THE ADMINISTRATION. TODAY WE
ARE PASSING A BUDGET THAT
STANDS ON ITS OWN IN MEETING
OUR CONSTITUTIONAL DEADLINE FOR
PASSING A BALANCED BUDGET BY
JUNE FIFTEENTH. I KNOW THIS WAS
POINTED OUT ON THE FLOOR LAST
YEAR. THE CONSTITUTION PROVIDES
TWO KEY DEADLINE REQUIREMENTS
FOR THE ANNUAL STATE BUDGET
FIRST REQUIRES THE GOVERNOR TO
PRESENT A BUDGET BY JANUARY
TENTH EVERY YEAR SECOND IT
REQUIRES THE LEGISLATURE TO
PASS A BALANCED BUDGET. BY JUNE
FIFTEENTH OF EVERY YEAR BUT
NOTHING IN THE CONSTITUTION
REQUIRES THE GOVERNOR. TO ONLY
PRESENT A BUDGET THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS ALREADY AGREED
TO AND SIMILARLY NOTHING IN THE
CONSTITUTION REQUIRES THE
LEGISLATURE TO ONLY PASS THE
BUDGET THAT THE GOVERNOR
PRESENTED. SOME TODAY THE
LEGISLATURE IS MEETING OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL OBLIGATION BY
PASSING A RESPONSIBLE BUDGET
THAT CONTINUES OUR DECADES LONG
EFFORT TO BUILD FISCAL
RESILIENCY WHILE UTILIZING A
HISTORIC LEVEL OF RESOURCES FOR
TRANSFORMATIVE INVESTMENTS.
THAT WILL PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT
BENEFITS FOR CALIFORNIANS. AND
OUR STATE AT THIS CRITICAL
JUNCTURE AND WITH THIS I ASK
FOR YOUR I. VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR SKINNER MEMBERS WE ARE
ON FILE ITEM FORTY NINE
ASSEMBLY BILL. ONE TWENTY
EIGHT. WHEN I MOVED TO A CENTER
MELINDA'S WHY A FOR PURPOSE YOU
RICE. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT-
AND THEIR AMENDMENT AT THE DESK
FORCE TO MOVE THE ONE TWENTY
EIGHT WHICH I WOULD LIKE TO
PRESENT. THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ THE
AMENDMENTS. AMENDMENTS BY
SENATOR MELENDEZ SAID ONE.
SIMILARLY AS YOU MAY PROCEED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATORS-
FOR WEEKS YOU HAVE HEARD ME
MAKE A MOTION AFTER MOTION
ATTEMPTING TO BRING US HERE
FIVE TO THE FLOOR FOR A VOTE
WHICH WOULD END THE GOVERNOR'S
DECLARED STATE OF EMERGENCY ON
COATED. THE GOVERNOR'S
UNCHECKED POWER SHOULD NOT
CONTINUE ESPECIALLY WITH
CALIFORNIA SUPPOSEDLY RE
OPENING TOMORROW AND IT IS
EXACTLY WHY I FIND IT TERRIBLY
CONFUSING THAT THIS BODY WILL
NOT APPROVE MY RESOLUTION BUT
IS PERFECTLY WILLING TO INCLUDE
IN THIS VERY BUDGET. A
TEMPORARY PAUSE TO THE GOVERNOR
TO THE GOVERNOR'S EMERGENCY
SPENDING POWERS. AND WIND. WHEN
WOULD THE GOVERNOR RECLAIM
THESE POWERS IN SEPTEMBER AT
THE END OF SESSION. IT IS TIME
TO END THE STATE OF EMERGENCY
NOW IT MAKES NO SENSE TO TAKE
THE GOVERNOR'S EMERGENCY
SPENDING POWERS AWAY
TEMPORARILY ONLY TO RESTORE
THEM DURING A TIME WHEN KEVIN
EMERGENCY NO LONGER EXISTS WE
ARE ABOUT TO AN ACTOR OUR
SECOND STATE BUDGET. SINCE THE
GOVERNOR TO PROCLAIM EMERGENCY
DUE TO COPE IT. SO HOW CAN HE
LOOK AT US WITH A STRAIGHT FACE
AND SAY THAT HE STILL NEEDS TO
BE ABLE TO EXECUTE EXERCISE
EMERGENCY SPENDING POWER. THIS
GOVERNOR HAS HAD AMPLE
OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD CODE
SPENDING INTO THE BUDGET.
AMENDMENT AT THE DESK DO
SOMETHING VERY SIMPLE WHICH IS
AN EMERGENCY SPENDING AUTHORITY
EFFECTIVE JUNE FIFTEENTH. IF
THE CRISIS IS INDEED OVER THEN
THERE IS NO LONGER A NEED FOR
THIS STATE OF EMERGENCY AND THE
GOVERNOR'S UNILATERAL AUTHORITY.
WE WRITE A LETTER ASKING THE
GOVERNOR TO JUSTIFY THE NEED
FOR AN EMERGENCY AND TO DISCUSS
WHERE THE PERIL OF THIS
EMERGENCY CURRENTLY EXISTS.
EIGHT STATES HAVE COMPLETELY
ENDED THEIR STATES OF EMERGENCY
WITH TWENTY MORE CONSIDERING
DOING SO BY THE END OF THE
MONTH. WE'VE BEEN UNDER THIS
EMERGENCY ORDER FOR FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY DAYS SENATOR. THE
CAPITAL IS FINALLY OPENING ITS
DOORS ONCE AGAIN TO BECOME THE
PEOPLE'S HOUSE. WE NEED TO TAKE
BACK OUR CONSTITUTIONAL
AUTHORITY IF THE CRISIS IS OVER
ENOUGH TO OPEN THE STATE
TOMORROW. THEN THERE IS NO
REASON TO ALLOW THE GOVERNOR TO
HAVE UNIT WATER- CONTROLLING
EMERGENCY SPENDING AUTHORITY
UNTIL JUNE OF NEXT YEAR
ABSOLUTELY NOT AND SO SENATORS.
I ASK FOR YOUR I. VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS AND OPPOSE ANY
MOTION TO TABLE THEM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR MELINDA'S SENATOR
HERTZBERG. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
PRESIDENT MOVED WITHIN MINUTES
OF THE TABLE. THANK YOU SIR
HERS BERG CENTER MELINDA'S HAS
AMENDMENTS AT THE TABLES IN
HERZBERG AS MOVE TO MOVE- LAY
THOSE ON THE TABLE. OR TAKE A
ROLL CALL VOTE CENTERS FOR IS
ASKING FOR MY VOTE SENATOR
MELINDA THIS IS ASKING FOR NO
VOTE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS I FACE NO BACKER. HI
FORGES NO BRADFORD HI BY ADAM I
CORTEZ HE HI DALLY NO DOT. I
THEY'RE AWESOME HI ADNAN I
LASER. I BEEN SOLID HIGH GROWTH.
NO HERTZBERG FIVE WEST SO. HER
TADO HI JONES NO KAMMERER I
LAYERED HI LLEVA I LIVE ALONE.
I REQUIRE I MELINDA'S NO MAN I
NEWMAN I NELSON NO A SHOW OF
BOTH. NO PAN I. FOURTEEN TINO I
BROUGHT. HI RUBIO I SKINNER. I
STERN I AM BERG I LIKE HOW SKI.
FIVE WINNER I WILL. NO. HIGHS
THIRTY KNOWS NINE MOTION PASSES
THE AMENDMENTS ARE LAID ON THE
TABLE WILL MOVE BACK O THIS
BILL IN CHIEF SENATOR SKINNER
HAS PRESENTED ON EIGHTY ONE
TWENTY EIGHT AND WILL MOVE TO
MOTION ARE AT THIS DISCUSSION
AND DEBATE ON AB ONE TWENTY
EIGHT SENATOR NIELSEN YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN OR MEMBERS. I'M GOING
TO URGE A NO VOTE ON THE BUDGET.
I WILL STIPULATE THAT THERE'S
MUCH IN THIS BUDGET. TO BE
ATTRACTED TO. MUCH THAT IS
POSITIVE. BUT THAT DOES NOT
OUTWEIGH WHAT I THINK ARE THE
NEGATIVE. ALL THE NEGATIVES
THERE'S A STANDARD HERE NOW
IT'S A PROCESS THAT DOESN'T
EXIST A BUDGET PROCESS. I USED
TO BE THAT THE BUDGET WAS
SUBMITTED SUBCOMMITTEES WOULD
MEET DELIBERATE. THEN THERE
WOULD BE A VOTE IN EACH HOUSE-
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE TO
RECONCILE THE DIFFERENCES IN
THE TWO HOUSE. THAT PROVIDED AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR LEGISLATE TORS
AND PROTECTING THE CITIZENS TO
DIRECTLY IMPORT THE BUDGET.
WELL FOR THE LAST TWO YEARS WE
HAVE NOT HAD A CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE. IT IN THAT IN A VERY
TOUGH BUDGET YEAR. WE DIDN'T
HAVE A CONFERENCE COMMITTEE AND
NOW IN A VERY POSITIVE. BUDGET
YEAR WE'RE NOT GOING TO HAVE A
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE I ASSUME
THAT THE CONFERENCE COMMITTEES
IN THE SENATE. THE DAYS ARE
DONE. THAT'S A SAD THING BUT
IT'S THE REALITY. OF THE TIME.
SO NOW WE DEAL WITH A PROCESS.
THERE IS COMPROMISE. THIS
MORNING IN BUDGET COMMITTEE THE
PUBLIC DID GET THE COMMENT I
THINK THERE WERE TWENTY FIVE
PEOPLE. GOT TO CALL IN FOR ONE
MINUTE. AND SAY I'M SO AND SO
AND I LIKE TO BUT- I DON'T LIKE
THE BUDGET. THAT'S THE EXTENT
OF THE PUBLIC INPUT. NO
SPECIFICS THAT THEY'RE ALLOWED
TO CONVEY. NO OTHER VENUE
THROUGH LEGISLATORS AS IN A
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE. SO
THEY'RE FROZEN OUT. NOW I CAN'T
BE THE RESIDENT HISTORIAN HERE
BUT THIS IS THE FIRST BUDGET.
THAT I REMEMBER VOTING FOR OR
AGAINST. WHERE IN THE GOVERNOR
HAD NOT MADE AN AGREEMENT WITH
THE MAJORITY PARTY. THAT'S NOT
THE CASE TODAY. YOU'RE BETTING
THE FUTURE THAT THERE WILL BE A
RESOLUTION WITH THE MAJORITY
AND THE GOVERNOR ON MANY ISSUES.
I TRUST THEY WILL BE BUT
THEY'RE GONNA FOLLOW THEN IN
THIS PLETHORA. NOW APPROACH TO
NINETY FIVE BILLS NOT BOOKS
THAT'S JUST OBSCENE. AND MANY
OF THESE PROVISIONS AND BILLS.
IN THE TRAILER BELOW DELUGE
WILL BE MAJOR POLICY. DON'T GO
THROUGH ANY POLICY COMMITTEE
HEARING. I DON'T HAVE ANY
PUBLIC INPUT IT'S JUST A JOB.
THAT IS NO WAY TO CONDUCT THE
LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS. MEETING
STATUTORY BUSINESS OR
LEGISLATIVE OR BUDGET BUSINESS
BUT THAT'S THE WAY WE'RE DOING
THESE DAYS. THE. IN A YEAR OF
NOW SURPLUS LAST YEAR WE HAD A
HECK OF A DEATH NO GO AHEAD THE
SURPLUS WELL WE'RE STILL
DRAWING FROM THE RESERVES EVEN
IN THIS YEAR. A SURPLUS.
DRAWING FROM THE USERS AND
DOING SOME VIRUS NOW WE'RE
DOING A LITTLE BIT OF DEBT
RETIREMENT BUT NOT NEARLY
ENOUGH. WITH THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY THAT WE HAVE AVAILABLE.
AND WHAT WOULD MOST ASSUREDLY
DOING IS BUILDING THE BASE FOR
THE FUTURE. AND CLOTHING AS
RETIRED BY THE GOVERNOR
CREATING A BUNCH OF NEW
DEPARTMENTS. NOT DEPARTMENTS DO
NOTHING IN GOVERNMENT EXCEPT
GIRL. THEY DON'T GROW SMALLER
THEY EXPAND THEIR AUTHORITIES.
EVERY YEAR COME IN FOR MORE HE
Y. H. GET BIGGER AND BIGGER.
ALL THE ALL NECESSARY I DON'T
THINK YOU COULD ARGUE ANY OF
ALL OF THE ANY OF THESE WHO ARE
WORTHY OF A DEPARTMENT STATUS
OR THAT WE WOULD BE CRIPPLED
WITHOUT HAVING DEPARTMENT
STATUS. FOR THE- BUT THAT IS
THE DEAL WERE DEALT WITH TODAY.
AND WE ARE A BLIGHT GENE THE
BLAST NEW INFLATION. CASH
EXPANDING TO THE FIFTY OR OLDER
REGARDLESS OF STATUS. IT'S
GONNA END UP COSTING UP TO A
BILLION DOLLARS. IN FUTURE
BUDGETS. A BILLION DOLLARS. NOW
IN THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE IS NOT
NEW BUT IT HAS NOT BEEN
EXTENSIVELY REVIEWED. IN
COMMITTEE. AND IT'S BEING
FORCED UPON US. IN THE CLOSING
MOMENTS OF THIS BUDGET. IT'S A
PRUDENT BUDGET I WOULD ARGUE
NOT. IT'S A HELPFUL BUDGET AND
SOME THINGS THAT WE DIDN'T HAVE
TO REDUCE ARE GETTING TO BE
RESTORED. AND MANY OF US COULD
SUPPORT THAT. IF NOT ALL OF US.
BUT NOT THE WHOLE PACKAGE AND
NOT THE WHOLE PROCESS. AND THUS
I URGE A NO VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR NELSON SENATOR BATES
FOLLOWED BY SENATOR MELINDA IS.
THEIR FATE THANK YOU HOME MR
PRESIDENT I'D LIKE TO
UNDERSCORE ALL COMMENTS OF MY
GOOD COLLEAGUE FROM TO HIM-
REGARDING- THE REVENUES THE
WINDFALL REVENUES. AND MY
CONCERN ABOUT THE BUDGET THAT'S
BEFORE US DESPITE THE RECORD
SITTING WINDFALL REVENUES BOTH
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AND
THIS ONE BEFORE US TODAY STILL
BORROW MONEY AND WITHDRAWAL
RESERVES TO DRIVE SPENDING EVEN
HIGHER. BOTH PROPOSALS FAILED
THE FAILED TO RESTORE FUNDING
THAT WAS TAKEN FROM THE RAINY
DAY FUND LAST YEAR WHEN WE AT
THAT TIME WE DID THINK WE HAVE
A DEFICIT IN TENS OF BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS. THESE CURRENT
PROPOSALS INCLUDE WITHDRAWING
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
RAINY DAY FUND IN THE CURRENT
YEAR AND IN ADDITION BORROWING
FROM SPECIAL FUNDS THE
NONPARTISAN LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE ADVISED
AGAINST THESE IRRESPONSIBLE
TACTICS IT SHOULD BE COMMON
SENSE TO REVERSE BUDGET SAVINGS
ACTIONS NOW. THAT THE BUDGET
HAS DRAMATICALLY TURNED AROUND
DOES ANYONE REALLY THINK THAT
THE VOTERS WHO OVERWHELMINGLY
REMEMBER THEY OVERWHELMINGLY
VOTED TO CREATE THE RAINY DAY
FUND. I THOUGHT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
WOULD NOT FULLY FUND THE RAINY
DAY FUND IN A YEAR WHEN WE ARE
SEEING RECORD REVENUES EVEN
WORSE THIS ANYONE THINK THAT
THE VOTERS THOUGHT THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
WOULD BE BORROWING. FROM THE
RAINY DAY FUND IN A YEAR WITH
RECORD REVENUES I THINK NOT FOR
THESE REASONS I CANNOT SUPPORT
THESE ACTIONS TODAY SO I URGE A
NO VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
BATES SENATOR MELINDA'S. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT SENATORS THIS
IS NOT A BUDGET THIS IS A
BLUEPRINT TO MEET TOMORROW'S
JUNE FIFTEENTH DEADLINE UNDER
PROP TWENTY FIVE THE BUDGET
PROCESS HAS NOW BECOME A
SESSION LONG AFFAIR WITH VERY
LITTLE TRANSPARENCY PROVIDED TO
THE PUBLIC. FOR EXAMPLE THIS
BUDGET PROVIDES MORE FUNDING
FOR SCHOOLS BUT FAILS TO
ADDRESS PARENTS CONCERNS BY NOT
REQUIRING CHILDREN TO BE BACK
IN SCHOOL FULL TIME AND NOT. BE
AS SOON AS- THEY CONTINUE USED
USE THE BORROWING STRATEGY FROM
ONE YEAR WHEN KOBE WAS RAMPANT
IN THE STATE DID NOT HAVE A
CLEAR PICTURE OF ITS FINANCES.
AND I WILL ADMIT THAT THERE ARE
SOME GOOD THINGS IN THIS
BUDGET. FUNDING THE TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN RATE STUDY
FOR THE DDS COMMUNITY HELPING
SMALL BUSINESSES WITH GRANTS TO
RE OPEN. EXPANDING MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT BEDS AND FULLY
FUNDING THE BARSTOW VETERANS
HOME. BUT THIS IS NOT D. BUDGET.
WHY ARE WE CONTINUING TO BORROW
MONEY FROM THE RAINY DAY FUND
WITH ALL OF THE SURPLUS AND
FINDING THAT WE HAVE THAT DOES
NOT MAKE ANY SENSE TO ME WE
HAVE A DROUGHT DECLARATION
WE'RE NOT SPENDING A SINGLE
PENNY. NOT A SINGLE PENNY ON
NEW WATER STORAGE PROJECTS WITH
THE SPENDING PLAN. IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE VOTERS
WERE SOLD ON A GAS TAX INCREASE
TO PROVIDE FIVE BILLION IN
SPENDING FOR ROADS THAT REVENUE
IS NOW FIFTY BILLION. IS THERE
A NEED TO CONTINUE THE TAX ON
CALIFORNIANS WHEN GAS IS NOW
OVER FOUR DOLLARS A GALLON
NEARLY EVERYWHERE IN THE STATE.
IS THERE A NEED TO
AUTOMATICALLY INCREASE THE GAS
TAX NEXT MONTH. ADDITIONALLY
WHAT CAN BE MORE IMPORTANT THAN
FIXING THE BROKEN SYSTEMS AT
EDT WHICH YOU ARE ALL WELL
AWARE OF. HOW CAN THIS BUDGET
FAILED TO FIX THE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN FRAUD THAT HAD BEEN
ALLOWED. TO FALL INTO THE HANDS
OF INMATES AND FRAUDSTERS
INSTEAD OF UNEMPLOYED
CALIFORNIANS WHO ACTUALLY NEED
THE ASSISTANCE. AND FINALLY. I
FIND IT TO BE NONSENSE TO PAUSE
THE GOVERNOR'S EMERGENCY
SPENDING AUTHORITY WHEN WE CAN
TAKE IT AWAY PERMANENTLY RIGHT
NOW WITHIN I VOTE ON S. C. R.
FIVE THE REJECTION OF THE
AMENDMENTS THAT I OFFERED MAKE
NO SENSE WHEN YOU CONSIDER
THEIR INCLUSION AND THIS WITH
THE PAUSE BUTTON IN THIS BUDGET.
IF YOU WERE WILLING TO TAKE
YOUR POWER BACK BUT ONLY UNTIL
THE END OF SESSION. WHAT SENSE
DOES THAT MAKE. IF THE MAJORITY
PARTY IS WILLING TO ABDICATE
ITS RESPONSIBILITY TO THE
GOVERNOR. THEN WHY HAVE A
LEGISLATURE AT ALL. IS OUR ONLY
FUNCTION NOW RELEGATED TO
PASSING BILLS THAT ONLY ADD NEW
TEXT TO THE SHELVES AND SHELVES
OF LAWS AND REGULATIONS
CURRENTLY IN PLACE IS THAT NOW
OUR ONLY FUNCTION. I REJECT THE
PREMISE THAT OUR CONSTITUENTS
CENTERS TO SACRAMENTO TO MERELY
PASSED BILLS INSTEAD OF
FIGHTING FOR THE ISSUES AND
SPENDING PRIORITIES THAT AFFECT
THEM EVERY SINGLE DAY. AND
THERE'S A REASON ARTICLE ONE OF
OUR CONSTITUTIO OUTLINE THE
POWERS AND RESPONSIBILITIES OF
THE LEGISLATURE FIRST. IT WAS
TO ENSURE THE PEOPLE'S VOICE IS
ALWAYS HEARD BEFORE AN
EXECUTIVE. EXERTED THEIR WILL
IT IS TIME TO PUT THE PEOPLE
FIRST AND PASS A RESPONSIBLE
AND COMPLETE BUDGET. NOT JUST
THE OUTLINE OF ONE I WOULD ASK
RESPECTFULLY FOR YOUR NO VOTE
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT. THANK
YOU SENATOR MELINDA AS ANY
OTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE TWENTY EIGHT.
SENATOR TROUBLED. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON
THE NEXT BUDGET FOR THIS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THIS
BUDGET HAS GOOD INVESTMENTS IN
EDUCATION CHILDCARE AND HIGHER
EDUCATION. THIS BUDGET ALLOWS
ALLOCATE NEW FUNDING FOR
HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS INCLUDING
A BILLION DOLLARS IN N GOING
FLEXIBLE LOCAL FUNDING. IT
RESTORES SSI BUDGET CUTS FROM
PREVIOUS YEARS TO SUPPORT
INDIVIDUALS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND THE ELDERLY.
IT PROVIDES A ONE BILLION
DOLLARS FOR WATERVIEW REGIS
INCREASED FUNDING FOR PARK
GRANTS AND A HUNDRED MILLION
FOR SPECIAL DISTRICTS. I'M
THANKFUL FOR ALL OF THE
DISCUSSIONS I'VE HAD WITH MY
COLLEAGUES ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE TO HIGHLIGHT THESE ISSUES.
THANK YOU ALSO FOR THE
INVESTMENTS IN OUR COMMUNITY
AND FOR FULFILLING SEVERAL OF
MY BUDGET REQUEST. DESPITE ALL
THESE GOOD THINGS I HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE AMOUNT OF
TAXPAYER DOLLARS ARE BEING SENT
OUT IN THE STATE WITHOUT ANY
ACCOUNTABILITY DETAILS ARE
REPORTING ASSOCIATED WITH IT.
THERE ARE SEVENTEEN POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS IN FINES IN
THIS BUDGET WHICH LIT WHICH
LITTLETON NO DETAIL IS
AVAILABLE. WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE MONEY THAT THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA HAVE GIVEN US IS
USED EFFICIENTLY. FOR THESE
REASONS I'LL BE UPSTANDING
TODAY BUT LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING REVISIONS OF THIS BUDGET
IN FUTURE TRAILER BILLS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR TROUBLE
GET ANY OTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
TWENTY EIGHT ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE SINNERS CAN I WOULD LIKE
TO CLOSE. THANKS SO MUCH- I
APPRECIATE THAT OUR COLLEAGUES
FROM THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
AISLE- DID PRAISE MANY ASPECTS
OF THIS BUDGET. BECAUSE I THINK
IT'S A GREAT BUDGET BUT ALLOW
ME TO CORRECT A FEW OF THE
THINGS THAT WERE REFERENCED.
FIRST OFF. THIS IS NOT THE
FIRST TIME THAT WE HAVE
APPROVED A BUDGET BEFORE WE
HAVE COME TO THE FULL
AGREEMENT- WE PASSED TO A
BUDGET LAST YEAR- INSTANCE PROP
TWENTY FIVE WE'VE ACTUALLY HAD
A NUMBER OF TIMES WHERE. THERE
WERE STILL A FEW THINGS TO WORK
OUT AND- BEFORE WE ARE AT THE
WYNDHAM MEN MINTS THAT WE HAD
TO DO- BEFORE WE HAD ASSIGNED
BUDGET SO THIS IS NOT UNUSUAL.
AND THE OTHER POINT THAT I
WANTED TO CORRECT IS THIS ISSUE
OF THAT WE THAT THIS BUDGET
THAT WHAT THEY ARE SPENDING
PLAN. IS BASED ON BORROWING
FROM THE RESERVES NOT AT ALL.
THERE WAS THE WITHDRAWAL OF THE
RESERVES IN THE BUDGET WE
THE EXPECTATION OF DROP IN
REVENUE. WHICH OF COURSE WOULD
FORTUNATELY DID NOT EXPERIENCE
AND SO THIS YEAR'S BUDGET. NOT
ONLY RESTORES THAT BUT IT
INCREASES THE DEPOSITS IN OUR-
BSA ARE MEETING OUR BUDGET
SURPLUS ACCOUNT OUR SAFETY NET
RESERVE IN OUR PROP NINETY
EIGHT SCHOOLS RESERVE. AND THE
RAINY DAY FUND RIGHT NOW HAS
ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION MORE
THAN IS CONSTITUTIONALLY
REQUIRED SO WE ACTUALLY WITH
THE ADOPTION OF THIS BUDGET
WILL HAVE THE HIGHEST RESERVES
YET EVER IN THE STATE'S
HISTORY. SO I JUST WANTED TO
CORRECT THAT ONE I'M IN
ADDITIONALLY. THERE WERE SOME
REFERENCE IN THE- COMMITTEE
THAT PERHAPS THIS WAS NOT
BALANCE TO THAT WE WOULD BE
FACING A DEFICIT IMMEDIATELY
NEXT YEAR. IN FACT THE-
PROJECTION BASED ON
EXPENDITURES HERE ARE FOR A
BALANCED BUDGET FOR THE NEXT
FOUR FISCAL YEARS. SO I THINK
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD
BE VERY PROUD ABOUT I THINK
THIS IS A BUDGET THAT REALLY
HELPS CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE
BEEN SO AS WE KNOW ALL OF US
IMPACTED BY THIS PANDEMIC
WHETHER IT'S OUR BUSINESSES OUR
FAMILIES. THERE ARE NONPROFITS
ARE CULTURAL INSTITUTIONS OUR
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS ARE
SCHOOLS YOU NAME IT WE HAVE. IN
THIS BUDGET. OUR SCHOOLS WILL
HAVE THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF PROP
NINETY EIGHT FUNDING AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER WE OBVIOUSLY
ARE GOOD NOT ONLY. BRINGING
CHILDCARE BACK FULLY BUT
GREATLY EXPANDING IT SO THAT
THE WOMEN IN THE WORK FORCE CAN
RETURN TO THE WORK FORCE WHICH
WE KNOW OUR BUSINESSES NOW. OUR
BUSINESSES ARE SAYING THAT YOU
KNOW THEY'VE DAY CONNIE WANTS
TO ROAR BACK AND YET. SOME
PEOPLE HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO GO
BACK TO WORK YET HI THEY CAN'T
LEAVE HOME YET BECAUSE OF
COURSE. THERE ARE STILL PEOPLE
THAT NEED TO BE CAREFUL KERO.
SO THIS BUDGET DOES ALL OF THAT
AND SO MUCH MORE AND WE SHOULD
FEEL SO PROUD OF IT AND WITH
THAT I ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS.
THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA HI AT KINS I
FACE NO BACKER. HI FOR JUST NO
BRADFORD HI BY ADAM HI CORTEZ
V. I. DALLY. NO DODD HI THERE
ALSO HI A COMMON HI GLAZER HI
GONZALEZ HIGH GROWTH. NO
HERTZBERG HI LISTEN. HER TADO
HI JONES NO CAN WATER I LAYERED
I LABOR I THE MON HI WIRE I
MELINDA'S NO MAN I NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN. NO A SHOW OF BOTH. PAN
I FORTUNE TINO I BROUGHT I
RUBIO HI SKINNER I STERN I AM
BERG I LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER. I
WILL NO. HIGHS THIRTY KNOWS
EIGHT MAJOR PASSES. MEMBERS
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO THE
REGULAR AGENDA FOR THE DAY.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED TO READ MESSAGES FROM
THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED
READ REPORTS OF COMMITTEE WILL
BE DEEMED RED AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. FOR MOVING ONTO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS IS
THERE ANY MEMBER THAT NEEDS TO
BE. SENATOR MELINDA'S. SENATOR
MILLER HAS A PURPOSE TO RICE
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I RISE
FOR TWO DIFFERENT REASONS TODAY
THE FIRST ONE BEING- PURSUANT
TO SENATE RULE TWENTY EIGHT
MAKING MOTION TO WITHDRAW I SEE
R. FIVE FROM THE SENATE
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE BROUGHT TO THE SENATE
FLOOR FOR A FULL AN ROBUST
DEBATE. ONE MORE CHANCE IT'S
BEEN FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT
DAYS. SINCE THE DECLARATION OF
A STATE OF EMERGENCY AND I
BROUGHT UP. AMENDMENTS EARLIER-
THOSE DID NOT PASS. BUT AGAIN I
WILL REITERATE EVERYONE IN
CALIFORNIA WHO WANTS A VACCINE
CAN GET ONE OR SCHOOLS. ARE
WELL WERE TEMPORARILY BACK IN
SESSION- BUSINESSES SUPPOSEDLY
WILL BE RE OPENING THINGS WILL
SUPPOSEDLY BE GOING BACK TO
NORMAL THEREFORE. I DON'T SEE
ANY REASON TO CONTINUE THE
STATE OF EMERGENCY I KNOW THAT
THE GOVERNOR HAS HINTED. THAT
HE NEEDS THE STATE OF EMERGENCY
TO CONTINUE SO THAT HE HAS THE
FLEXIBILITY TO MOVE QUICKLY IN
THE EVENT THAT PERHAPS THERE'S
A SURGE OR SOMETHING ELSE TAKES
PLACE. AND I WOULD. RESPOND TO
THAT BY REMINDING YOU HOW
QUICKLY WE WERE ABLE TO MOVE
WHEN THE PANDEMIC FIRST HIT IN
MARCH AND HOW QUICKLY WE WERE
ABLE TO PUT THINGS INTO PLACE
TO MAKE SURE. THAT THE PUBLIC
WAS PROTECTED SO THERE IS NO
REASON TO KEEP THE STATE OF
EMERGENCY IN PLACE BECAUSE WE
CAN MOVE JUST AS QUICKLY. IN
THE FUTURE AS WE DID- BACK IN
MARCH SO WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE. THANK YOU SENATOR
MELINDA'S CENTER HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT A
JOURNALIST FOR NOVEL. SENATOR
HERTZBERG SENATOR MELINDA HAS
IS ASKING FOR AN I. VOTE.
SENATOR HERTZBERG IS ASKING FOR
A NO VOTE. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN.
SENATOR MELENDEZ IS ASKING FOR
AN I. VOTE SENATOR HERTZBERG IS
ASKING FOR THE NO VOTE THIS IS
OPPOSITE OF EARLIER IN THE DAY
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN. ONE MORE
TIME SENATOR MELINDA IS ASKING
FOR AN ICE IN HERS BERG IS
ASKING FOR NO. ALAN NO
ARCHULETA NO ADKINS NO BATES.
HI BACKER NO PORGES. HI
BRADFORD NO CUT BY ADAM. NO
CORTESE NO DALLY I DOG NO
THEY'RE ALSO NO EGBIN. NO
GLAZER NO GUNS ALLAH'S NO
GROWTH. HI HURTS BERG. NO WAY
SO. HER TADO NO JONES I CAN
LONGER NO LAYERED NO LLEVA NO-
MON NO MCGUIRE NO MELINDA'S I
MEN. NO NEWMAN WHO KNOWS
NIELSEN I A SHOW OF BOTH. HI
PAM. NO PARTS AND YOU KNOW NO
ROSS. NO RUBIO. NO SKINNER. NO
STERN NO AMBERG NO WAY CASKEY
NO WINNER. NO WILKE HI HIGHS
NINE KNOWS THIRTY MOTION FAILS.
A SINNER MELINDA'S THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I STAND TODAY TO
NOTIFY THE SENATE AND THE
PUBLIC THAT I HAVE SUBMITTED A
LETTER TO THE JOURNAL WHICH HAS
BEEN APPROVED BY BOTH CAUCUSES
THE RECORD SHOWS ABSTENTIONS ON
TWO BILLS SB TWENTY TWO AND SB
SEVEN OH EIGHT WHICH WERE
BROUGHT UP ON CONSENT CALENDAR
DAYS FOR WHICH I WAS ABSENT SO
WITH THIS LETTER I WOULD LIKE
TO NOTE THAT I AM FULLY
SUPPORTIVE OF THOSE TWO PIECES
OF LEGISLATION THANK YOU THANK
YOU SIR MELINDA'S THE DECIBEL
NOTE. MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION
THE SENATE JOURNALS FOR THE
WEEK OF JUNE SEVENTH THROUGH
JUNE TENTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE
WILL BE APPROVED AND CORRECTED
BY THE MINUTE CLARK. MEMBERS
REMOVING ON TODAY CONSIDERATION
OF THE DAILY FILE. WE'RE GOING
TO GO TO SECOND READING FILES
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION FORTY ONE
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE EIGHTY ONE
WITH AMENDMENTS THREE ASSEMBLY
BILL. 439-104-3364. SIXTY FOUR
NINE TWENTY FIFTEEN EIGHTY ONE
FIFTEEN NINETY TWO AN ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVEN FORTY NINE WITH
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS. IF
SENATOR BATES IS READY. SENATOR
BATES YOU DESERVE PRESIDENT
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN IS
THE CONFIRMATION OF PAROLE
BEING AS GENERAL COUNSEL AND
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT PRIOR TO THIS ROLE
IS BEING SERVED AT LEGAL AID AT
WORK FORMALLY LEGAL AID SOCIETY
FOR SEVERAL YEARS MOST RECENTLY
AS A SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY IN
ITS WAGE PROTECTION PROGRAM SHE
WAS APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON JUNE NINTH A
UNANIMOUS FIVE ZERO VOTE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOAT THANK YOU SURVEYS MEMBERS
WERE ON GOVERNOR APPOINTEES
FILE ITEM FOURTEEN IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS
I BASE. I BACKER. I FORGES I
BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM HI
COURTESY HI DALLY. I DON. I-
ALSO HI ADMIN I GLAZER. I
GONZALEZ I GROWTH I HEARD
SPURRED I WAS SO. HER TADO HI
JONES I CAN LONGER I LAYERED HI
LLEVA HI THE MON I REQUIRE. HI
MELINDA'S. I MEAN I NEWMAN I
NELSON HI A CHILL OF BOTH I CAN.
FIVE PERSONS YOU KNOW I. ROSS I
RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN I AM
BERG I LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER I
WILL. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. WEST SO. WELL. HIGHS
THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED.
SENATOR BATES. WELL I'M.
SIXTEEN BYLINE TO NUMBER
SIXTEEN IS THE CONFIRMATION OF
ANNA MARIE ARBELA FARIAS AND
FREDERICK WHITE TO THE HOUSING
FINANCE AGENCY BOARD OF
DIRECTORS WE HAVE A BE A VERY
US HAS SERVED ON THE BOARD
SINCE TWENTY FIFTEEN HE WAS
OPERATIONS DIRECTOR AT JUVENILE
HALL AUXILIARY OF CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY MR WHITE IS THE HOUSING
CAPITAL ADVISER FOR THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES OFFICE OF CITY
HOMELESSNESS INITIATIVES. BOTH
APPOINTEES WERE APPROVED BY THE
SENATE RULES COMMITTEE ON JUNE
NINTH ON A FIVE ZERO VOTE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BUILT THANK YOU SENATOR BATES
MEMBERS RUN FILE ITEM SIXTEEN
GOVERNORS APPOINTEES IS THERE
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA I AT KINS I BATES
FIVE BACKER. FIVE BARGES HI
BRADFORD. HI BY ADAM HI CORTESE
I DALLY I DON. HI THERE ALSO BY
ADMIN I LASER. HI CONSOLIDATES
HIGH GROWTH. HI HURTS BERG I
LISTEN. HER TADO HI JONES FIVECAN LONGER I LAYERED HI LLEVA I
THE MON I REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S
FIVE MILLION FIVE NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. I A SHOW OF BOTH. HI
PAM FIVE FORTUNE TINO HI RALPH.
HI RUBIO HI SKINNER. HI STERN I
AM BERG I LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER
I WILL HI. SIZE THIRTY NINE NO
ZERO APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED
TO MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO THE SENATE THIRD READING
FILE WE HAVE TWO RESOLUTIONS
THAT WE'RE GONNA TAKE UP THIS
AFTERNOON FILE ITEM TWENTY
EIGHT AND FINAL ITEM THIRTY
FILE ITEM TWENTY EIGHT IS UP
FIRST WITH SENATOR- BERGEN SCR
THREE. SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
THREE BY SENATOR UMBERG
RELATIVE TO VETERANS CENTER
NUMBER. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO PRESENT S.
C. R. THREE TO COMMEMORATE.
VETERANS OF THE REPUBLIC OF
VIETNAM ARMED FORCES DAY THIS
WRECK RESOLUTION RECOGNIZES
JUNE NINETEENTH. AS VETERANS OF
THE REPUBLIC OF VIETNAM ARMED
FORCES DAY IN MEMORY OF THE
SOLDIERS WHO SACRIFICED THEIR
LIVES. FOR FREEDOM AND
DEMOCRACY AND THE VICTIMS OF
THE VIETNAM WAR IN HONOR OF THE
SURVIVORS ACTIVISTS AND FREEDOM
FIGHTERS OF THAT WAR AROUND THE
WORLD. CURRENTLY VIETNAMESE
AMERICANS RECOGNIZE THE
REPUBLIC OF VIETNAM ARMED
FORCES DAY ON JUNE NINETEENTH
OF THIS YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
MARKS THE FIFTY SIXTH
ANNIVERSARY OF THIS ANNUAL
COMMEMORATION. THE UNITED
STATES AS WELL AS IN CALIFORNIA
IN ORANGE COUNTY. THESE
MILITARY PERSONNEL. HAVE BEEN A
STRONG VOICE FOR DEMOCRACY
RELIGIOUS FREEDOM AND HUMAN
RIGHTS IN VIETNAM AND
CONTRIBUTE CULTURALLY AND
ECONOMICALLY TO OUR SOCIETY
INTO THE DIVERSITY OF OUR
NATION. AS A VETERAN IT'S MY
HONOR TO RECOGNIZE ALL THOSE
VIETNAMESE AMERICAN RESIDENTS
IN CALIFORNIA WILL CELEBRATE
THIS DAY. IN RECOGNITION OF
THOSE WHO FOUGHT BRAVELY FOR
INDEPENDENCE AND THEIR FAMILIES
I WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE
SENATOR PIANOS CO AUTHORED
CENTER NEWMAN IS CO AUTHOR- WHO
WILL BE ADDED LATER IN SUPPORT
OF S. C. R. THREE RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR EYEBALLS. THANK YOU
SERRA BERG MEMBERS THIS IS FILE
ITEM TWENTY EIGHT STR THREE IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SENATOR ARCH ALETTA YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I RISE IS THE CHAIR
OF THE MILITARY VETERANS
COMMITTEE AND- I THANK CENTER
ON BIRD FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD IN AND THE CO AUTHORS.
WE ALWAYS MUST REMEMBER OUR
VIETNAM VETERANS AND OF COURSE
THOSE WHO SERVED SIDE BY SIDE.
IN THE VIETNAM WAR BROUGHT MORE
THAN TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
MEMBERS OF THE SOUTH VIETNAMESE
ARMED FORCES AND MORE THAN
FIFTY EIGHT THOUSAND OF OUR OWN
AMERICAN. WHO LOST THEIR LIVES
IN THE FIGHT FOR FREEDOM
CONTINUES TODAY AS ALWAYS BUT
WE WANT TO REMEMBER THAT WHEN
WE THINK OF THE FALL OF SAIGON
APRIL THIRTIETH NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE WE HAVE TO THINK
OF. THE SOUTH VIETNAMESE WHO
WERE THERE THE AMERICAN
SOLDIERS AND I URGE AND I VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR ARCHER LET ANY
OTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
S. ZERO THREE. ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. CINEMARK
DO YOU WANT TO CLOSE. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT CALLING SATURDAY
NIGHT BOTH THANK YOU THANK YOU
SARAH BURKE SECRETARY CALLED-
AT LEAST JOHN THIS QUALIFIES
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION. TO USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING NONE. HIGHS THIRTY
NINE NO ZERO MAJOR PASSES WE'RE
GONNA FILE ITEM THIRTY S. C. R.
FIFTY CENT A ROAD SHOW VOGUE.
APPEARS TO BE READY SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION FIFTY BY SENATOR A
CHILL UP BOTH RELATIVE TO
ALZHEIMER'S AND BRIT BRING
AWARENESS MONTH AND THE LONGEST
DAY. CENTRE TROUBLE. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS. SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION FIFTY
RECOGNIZES THE MONTH OF JUNE
TWENTY TWENTY FIRST AS
ALZHEIMER'S AND BRAIN AWARENESS
MONTH IN JUNE TWENTIETH OF THIS
YEAR AS THE LONGEST DAY IN
CALIFORNIA. S. YOU'RE FIFTY
ALSO URGES ALL CALIFORNIANS TO
COMMEMORATE THIS DAY TO HELP
SPREAD GLOBAL AWARENESS OF THE
ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION'S
VISION OF A WORLD WITHOUT
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE.
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE IS A
PROGRESSIVE NEURO DEGENERATIVE
BRAIN DISORDER THAT TRAGICALLY
ROBS INDIVIDUALS OF THEIR
MEMORIES AT LEAST TWO COGNITIVE
DECLINE RESULTING IN FUNCTIONAL
EMOTIONAL AND BEHAVIORAL
IMPAIRMENTS. IT IS ALWAYS FATAL
AND IT IS THE THIRD LEADING
CAUSE OF DEATH IN CALIFORNIA
THIRD. WITH SIX HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY THOUSAND RESIDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA LIVING WITH THIS
DISEASE ALZHEIMER'S IS A VERY
PREVALENT DISEASE THAT HAS
IMPACTED MOST IF NOT EVERYONE
ON THIS FLOOR IN SOME WAY. FOR
ME IT HAS BEEN PERSONAL I'VE
HAD TWO GRANDMOTHERS PASSED
AWAY FROM ALZHEIMER'S INCLUDING
THE MOST RECENT ONE JUST TWO
WEEKS AFTER I CAME TO THE US
ONE HERE IN THE AREA ON THE
SENATE FLOOR. AND I HAVE TO SAY
THAT. HAD WE BEEN A LITTLE MORE
AWARE OF WHAT ALZHEIMER'S LOOK
HOW WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE. IN THE
REAL WORLD AND HOW IT AFFECTS
PEOPLE'S PERSONAL LIVES WE
WOULD HAVE BEEN BETTER PREPARED.
I WITNESSED THE- THE PHYSICAL
EMOTIONAL PSYCHOLOGICAL TOLL
AND FAMILY MEMBERS AND THOSE
CLOSE TO OR TO MY GRANDMOTHER'S.
AND TRULY HOPE THAT WE CAN USE
THIS DAY THIS MONTH TO BECOME
FULLY AWARE OF WHAT IT LOOKS
LIKE. BEFORE IT IS FORMALLY
DIAGNOSED SO THAT WE MAY KNOW
WHAT TO LOOK FOR. OTHERS
DISEASE DOES NOT JUST IMPACT
THOSE WERE DIAGNOSED BUT ALSO
PUTS A SIGNIFICANT STRAIN ON
THEIR LOVED ONES. INDIVIDUALS
LIVING WITH ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE
AND THEIR CAREGIVERS NEED
ACKNOWLEDGMENT SUPPORT AND THE
TOOLS TO MEET THEIR NEEDS OVER
THE LINK THE PROGRESSION OF THE
DISEASE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. HAVE A- THANK YOU
SENATOR TROUBLED MEMBERS MOVING
ON TO DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
SENATOR RUBIO YOUR RECOGNIZE.
OKAY. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
SENATE I ALSO RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF S. C. R. FIFTY AND I
WANT TO THINK THAT GREAT
SENATOR FROM YOU KIND BEFORE
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AS SHE
ALREADY STATED THAT THIS
DISEASE IS. HEARTBREAKING AND
ALL OF US HERE NO EITHER
SOMEONEPERSONALLY OR A FAMILY
MEMBER DEALING WITH THIS IN HER
OWN FAMILY TWO GRANDMOTHERS IN
ONE FAMILY THAT JUST GIVES US A
SENSE OF HOW PRO PROVIDED LET
THIS DISEASE YES BUT TODAY I
WANTED TO TACKLE HER REMARKS
BUT ALSO AT THE VOICE OF
SEBASTIAN GOOSE MON WHO IS A
YOUNG LITTLE BOY IN MY
COMMUNITY WHO ACTUALLY WROTE A
LETTER TO ME SINCE HOW IT
HIGHLIGHTING HOW DEVASTATING
THIS LESS FOR HIM AS A YOUNG
CHILD HE DISCUSSED HIS
GRANDFATHER. AND HOW HE SAW HIS
GRANDFATHER JANICE DETERIORATE
AND FORGET WHO HE WAS HE FORGOT
HOW TO EAT HOW TO TALK HE EVEN
SAID HOW TO BREED AND I JUST
WANTED TO NOT ONLY HIGHLIGHT
HIS STORY BUT SO MANY OTHERS IT
IS REALLY EXTREMELY SAD TO SEE
THAT SOMEONE YOU KNOW IN FRONT
OF YOU IS DEALING WITH SUCH A
HORRIFIC AND DEBILITATING BRAIN
DISEASE SO I WANT TO ADD MY
VOICE AND I WANT TO ALSO JUST
ENCOURAGED THE AWARENESS OF
WHAT IT IS AND REALLY FOCUS ON.
TRYING TO FIND A CURE IN THE
NEAR FUTURE AGAIN ON BEHALF OF
SONIA GOOSE MON AND SEBASTIAN
GOOSE MON WHO DEALT WITH THE
SOLE PERSONALLY AND TOOK THE
TIME TO WRITE TO ME AND TO
ENSURE THAT I UNDERSTAND HOW
IMPORTANT WAS TO THEM AND I
PERSONALLY HAVE NO FRIENDS AND
FAMILY MEMBERS AND SO WITH THAT
I ALSO URGE AND I BOTH THANK
YOU THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO
CENTER OF THE MON. FALL RIGHT
CENTER PANTS SENATOR LAMONT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AT MISTER
PRINCE TODAY RISING SUPPORT OF
C. R. FIFTY AND THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM YOU GUYS BACK
FOR BRINGING THIS IMPORTANT
RESOLUTION FORWARD SOME OF YOU
KNOW THAT HALL'S AMR'S IS CLOSE
TO MY HEART AND ALSO A PERSONAL
ISSUE. I WATCH MY GRANDMOTHER
PASSED AWAY FROM ALZHEIMER'S I
ALSO HAVE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE TO TAKE
A VERY PERSONAL SITUATION THAT
IMPACTS SO MANY FAMILY MEMBERS
AND WORK ON THIS ISSUE. THE
POLICY LANDS. I HAVE WATCHED
HOW TRAGICALLY ALZHEIMER'S ROBS
INDIVIDUALS OF THEIR MEMORIES
THEIR BODILY FUNCTIONS ANY
MOTIONS. I HAVE SEEN HOW THIS
DISEASE AFFECTS AN ENTIRE
FAMILY UNIT. BUT I HAVE ALSO
WITNESSED THE STRENGTH THE
PASSION AND INDIFFERENCE OF THE
PEOPLE WHO FACE ALZHEIMER'S
DISEASE. TODAY WE HONOR THOSE
PEOPLE WE HONOR THE CARE GIVERS
WE HONOR THE FAMILY MEMBERS WE
HONOR THE FRIENDS WHO HAVE
PROVIDED SO MUCH NEEDED SUPPORT.
TODAY WE ESPECIALLY RECOGNIZE
OUR LOVED ONES PAST AND PRESENT
WHO HAVE BEEN IMPACTED BY THIS
DISEASE. TODAY I RESPECTFULLY
ASPIRIN I VOTE. THANK YOU
CEREMONY SENATOR PAN. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT CENTERS I TO RISE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF ITS YOUR
FIFTY AND ONE THANK MY GOOD
FRIEND FROM YOUR TRIBE OF FOR
HER LEADERSHIP IN BRINGING THIS
FORWARD- SO IMPORTANT THAT- WE
RECOGNIZE THE IMPACT-
ALZHEIMER'S HAS ON OUR FAMILIES
OUR COMMUNITY IN OUR STATE. I
KNOW IT'S HERE AT IN THE STATE
SENATE- WE'VE BEEN WORKING HARD
TO TAKE A LEADERSHIP ROLE IN
ADDRESSING ISSUES RELATED TO
ALZHEIMER'S AND DEMENTIA AND
THOSE ARE THE FACTS- IN THIS
VERY BUDGET THAT WE JUST PASSED
EARLIER. IN THE SESSION-
THERE'S ACTUALLY FUNDING FOR-
ALZHEIMER'S- TRAINING AND- AS
WELL AS IN A WAY I THINK AND
RECOGNIZE MY GOOD FRIEND FROM
SANTA BARBARA WHO JUST SPOKE TO
HER LEADERSHIP AND A CHANGE
OVER LEGISLATION AS WELL TO
IMPROVE- DETECTION AND
DIAGNOSIS OF ALZHEIMER'S AS
WELL- THIS REALLY IS A
BIPARTISAN. MATTER I MEAN THIS
IS ABOVE AND BEYOND POLITICS
AND SO I'M GLAD TO SEE THAT WE
ARE- HOPEFULLY WE CAN ALL COME
TOGETHER- THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT
CONFRONTS US YOU KNOW OUR PATH
FORMER GOVERNOR AND PRESIDENT
RONALD REAGAN SUFFERED FROM
THIS IT'S SOMETHING WE CAN HELP
PLEASE JOIN TOGETHER TO. SAY
THAT WE NEED TO MUTUALLY
SUPPORT EACH OTHER AS
CALIFORNIANS AS AMERICANS TO
ADDRESS THIS DISEASE AND
SUPPORT THE FAMILIES AND ENSURE
THAT WE SUPPORT ALSO- THE
AVAILABLE TO CARE GIVERS- WHICH
IS AS WELL AND THAT- THAT- THAT
FAMILIES CAN FIND SUPPORT AND-
AND COMFORT- THE STATE CONFRONT
THIS TERRIBLE. DISEASE I
IMAGINE EITHER THANK YOU. AND
CENTER DRAWS. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I JUST TO ADD ON A
PERSONAL BASIS AS WELL MY
FATHER- HAD THE OLD TIMERS AND
IT WAS A VERY DEEPLY STRESSFUL
DEEPLY EMOTIONAL EXPERIENCE FOR
SEVERAL YEARS HE WAS BED
RIDDEN. AND I THINK THAT THE
HARDEST PART OF ALL WAS THAT HE
HAD NO OTHER ILLNESS HE HAD
NEVER TAKEN A PILL BEFORE HE
WAS DIAGNOSED DURING HIS
SEVERAL YEARS OF BEING BED
RIDDEN. NEVER HAD TO TAKE A
PILL FOR ANY OTHER ILLNESS AND
IT WAS SO HARD TO UNDERSTAND
FOR EVERYONE ESPECIALLY MY MOM
HELPS SOMEONE. COULD EVENTUALLY
PASS AWAY FROM ALL THESE OTHER
ISSUES- AND NEVER HAVING BEEN
ILL AT LEAST IN THE WAY THAT WE
UNDERSTOOD THAT THE ILLNESS SO-
I ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT AND
THANK THE AUTHOR THANK YOU
SENATOR DRAWS OF CENTERS ANY
OTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM ANY OTHER DISCUSSION
TO BE HONEST YOU'RE FIFTY.
CENTER TROUBLE WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. I JUST WANT TO SECOND
THE- THE COMMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN RAISED AND MENTIONED BY MY
COLLEAGUES. IT IS A TOUGH
DISEASE TO DEAL WITH ON A
PERSONAL LEVEL. AND I REALLY
WANT TO THINK- ALL OF OUR
MEMBERS FOR THEIR SUPPORT HIM
FOR THOSE WHO WERE THERE PURPLE
MASS TO SHOW THEIR SUPPORT
TODAY. I WOULD LIKE TO INVITE
YOU ALL TO MEET ME IN THE FRONT
OF THE CHAMBER AFTER SESSION
FOR A GROUP PICTURE. AND
ENCOURAGE YOU TO SPREAD
AWARENESS TO YOUR SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS USING THE HASHTAG ON
YOUR MASK HASHTAG END OF. E. N.
D. A. L. Z. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR IPHONE IN RECOGNITION
OF THOSE LIVING WITH THIS
TERRIBLE DISEASE AND THOSE WHO
LOVE THEM. THANK YOU SENATOR
TROUBLED MEMBERS THIS ALSO
QUALIFIES FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION. TO
USING UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON
THE SITE I'M SEEING NONE HIGHS
THIRTY NINE KNOWS ZERO MAJOR
PASSES. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
BACK TO- MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS MEMBERS. ANYONE
NEEDING TO BE RECOGNIZED FOR
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. SEEING
NONE. WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS CENTER
ADMIN. HAVE AN ANNOUNCEMENT FOR
COMMITTEES I DO THE UTILITIES
COMMITTEE WILL MEET IN THE
CHAMBER TWENTY MINUTES AT THE
CONCLUSION OF THIS SO THAT THAT
THREE TWENTY THREE TO CHILI'S
COMMITTEE WILL. START HERE IN
THE SENATE CHAMBER. THANK YOU
SENATOR EDMUND NOW MEMBERS WE
ARE GOING TO GO BACK TO THE
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS FOR
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. WE HAVE
THREE GERMANS IN MEMORY THIS
MORNING WE'RE GONNA RECOGNIZE
SENATOR SKINNER FIRST CENTER
SCANNERS YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANKS SO MUCH MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS FOR DECADES JOHN SUTTER
WAS AN ENVIRONMENTAL CHAMPION
AND AN ADVOCATE FOR THE
PRESERVATION OF OPEN SPACE AND
A COMMITTED. PUBLIC SERVANT HE
HAD THIRTY TWO YEARS IN ELECTED
OFFICE MULTIPLE YEARS AS
GOVERNOR PAT BROWN TO POINT YOU
TO THE ORIGINAL. A CONSERVATION
AND DEVELOPMENT COMMISSION M.
FOURTEEN YEARS ON THE BENCH AS
IN ALAMEDA COUNTY SUPERIOR
COURT JUDGE. I HAD THE HONOR OF
SERVING WITH JOHN ON THE EAST
BAY REGIONAL. PARK DISTRICT
BOARD OF DIRECTORS BEFORE I
JOINED THE STATE LEGISLATURE.
JOHN PASSED AWAY.ON MAY
FOURTEENTH HE WAS NINETY TWO
YEARS OLD AND IT WAS JUST ONE
MONTH AFTER THE DEATH OF HIS
BELOVED WIFE ELLIE ELOISE CONTE
WHO HE AND THE KELLY WERE
MARRIED FOR SIXTY FOUR YEARS
NOW IN ALL THE YEARS THAT MR
SIR. WHAT'S THE TIRELESS
ADVOCATE THAT HE WAS. AMONG HIS
MOST CELEBRATED ACCOMPLISHMENTS
WAS THE CREATION IN THE LAE
SEVENTIES OF THE SEVEN HUNDRED
AND FORTY ONE ACRE MARTIN
LUTHER KING JR REGIONAL
SHORELINE IN OAKLAND WHICH IS
AN URBAN OASIS NEAR THE BUSY
PORT OF OAKLAND COUNTY OAKLAND
INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT. AND
SOMEWHERE THAT IS WELL KNOWN
AND LOVED BY BIRD WATCHERS AND
JOHN HIMSELF LIKE TO WATCH. GO
THERE AND HIKE. SO ACCOMPLISHED
MUCH DURING HIS LONG CAREER
WITH LITTLE FANFARE AND LITTLE
EGO HE WAS CORDIAL SMART
UNDERSTATED TEN NATIONS AND
EFFECTIVE BECAUSE HE WAS
THOUGHTFUL. AND IT'S HAD AN
EVEN TEMPERAMENT AND A
TOLERANCE FOR OPPOSING VIEWS.
THE LONGTIME GENERAL MANAGER
THESE BE REGIONAL PARK DISTRICT
NOTED. THAT THERE ARE MANY
FEATURES IN THE EAST BAY BUT
THE PUBLIC WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
ENJOY WITHOUT THE TIRELESS
EFFORTS OF JOHN CENTER. JOHN
GREW UP IN OAKLAND HE GRADUATED
FROM OAKLAND HIGH SCHOOL HE GOT
HIS BA FROM HARVARD HIS LAW
DEGREE FROM STANFORD. HE
STARTED AS A PRIVATE ATTORNEY.
THEN SERVED AS ALAMEDA COUNTY
DEPUTY DA AND THEN AS I
MENTIONED FOURTEEN YEARS ON THE
BENCH. HE AND HIS WIFE RAISED
THREE DAUGHTERS. AND HE HIMSELF
DEVELOPED HIS APPRECIATION FOR
NATURE WHEN HIS PARENTS TOOK
HIM CAMPING IN THIS YEAR'S AS A
CHILD. LET ME JUST FINISH OFF
WITH SOME OF THE OTHER
ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF JOHNS IN THE
SIXTIES JOHN SIR WAS THE CO
FOUNDER OF A GROUP NOW KNOWN AS
THE GREEN BUILT ALLIANCE WHICH
STILL CARRIES ON HIS VISION OF
PROTECTING OPEN SPACE FOR URBAN
SPRAWL. AARON AS I MENTIONED.
THAT HE WAS ON THE EAST BAY
REGIONAL PARK DISTRICT FOR
TWENTY YEARS BOARD. AND HE
HELPED OVERSEE. THE PURCHASE OF
OPEN SPACE BY THAT DISTRICT. TO
THE POINT WHERE DAD DISTRICT IS
NOW THE LARGEST URBAN PARK
DISTRICT IN THE UNITED STATES
WITH A HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND ACRES OF OPEN SPACE.
WHICH IS BIGGER THAN GOLDEN
GATE NATIONAL RECREATION AREA
AND BIGGER THAN MANY MANY OF
OUR NATIONAL PARKS. SO LAST
SUMMER THESE BE REGIONAL PARK
DISTRICT LEGITIMATELY DEDICATED
A TWENTY TWO ACRE AREA AT THE
FOOT OF THE OAKLAND SEARCHES GO
BIG BRIDGE AS THE JUDGE JOHN
SUTTER REGIONAL SHORELINE.
BECAUSE HE WAS THE FIRST PERSON
MORE THAN FIFTY YEARS EARLIER
TO SUGGEST THAT THAT AREA OF
THE DAN OAKLAND ARMY BASE
SHOULD BE TURNED INTO A PUBLIC
PARK AT THE BASE WHICH EVER
CLOSED. AND SO OF COURSE NOW
THAT THE BASE IS CLOSED THE
PARK IS NAMED FOR JOHN. SO JOHN
SAID ONCE SOMETIMES YOU CAN GET
A LOT DONE WITH PERSEVERANCE
AND A LITTLE LUCK. AND HE SAID
PEOPLE HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
FIGHT FOR THEIR PARKS AT ALL
LEVELS AND YES WE DO AND JOHN
WE WILL AND YOU WILL BE GREATLY
MISSED BUT NEVER FORGOTTEN.
THANK YOU SIR SKINNER CENTER
PAN. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT-
CENTERS I RISE TO TURN IN
MEMORY OF PASTOR EMERITUS
SAMUEL FETUS MULLINAX WHO
PASSED AWAY AT THE AGE OF
EIGHTY FIVE IN SACRAMENTO HOME
ON MEMORIAL DAY MAY THIRTY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE. MR
MULLINAX WAS BORN IN MARLIN
TEXAS ON OCTOBER EIGHTH
NINETEEN THIRTY FIVE BEFORE
MOVING WITH HIS MOTHER.
PRESIDENT LEE LEWIS TO RICHMOND
CALIFORNIA WHERE YOU TENDED EL
CERRITO HIGH SCHOOL AND WAS
ACCOMPLISHED STUDENT ATHLETES.
ON JUNE TWENTY SIXTH NINETEEN
FIFTY THREE AFTER GRADUATING
HIGH SCHOOL MR MONEX AND LISTED
IN THE UNITED STATES ARMY.
WHERE HE SERVED OUR COUNTRY AS
A MEMBER OF THE FIVE HUNDRED
FOURTH PARACHUTE INFANTRY
REGIMENT UNDER THE EIGHTY
SECOND AIRBORNE DIVISION. HE
WAS STATIONED TORIA JAPAN AND
GERMANY BEFORE HIS HONORABLE
DISCHARGE ON ME. MARCH
NINETEENTH NINETEEN SIXTY TWO.
ON DECEMBER EIGHTEENTH NINETEEN
SIXTY FIVE MISTER MULLINAX
MARRIED HIS WIFE ERNESTINE
MULLINAX AND RELOCATE TO
SACRAMENTO WHERE HE SETTLED TO
RAISE YOUR FAMILY. MR MONEX
JOINS HIS WIFE IS A MEMBER OF
SHILOH MISSIONARY BAPTIST
CHURCH IN SACRAMENTO AND LATER
GRADUATED FROM CONROE NORMAL
INDUSTRIAL COLLEGE WITH A
DEGREE IN THEOLOGY. MR MALL AN
AXE JOIN THE PASTORAL STAFF IN
STAR LO AND WAS ORDAINED UNDER
THE MENTORSHIP OF SENIOR PASTOR
REVEREND. WILLIE P. COOK. NOW
RIVER MULLINAX RETURN TO
SERVICE AT THE LOGIC PROFESSOR
AT CONROE NORMAL AND INDUSTRIAL
COLLEGE AND AFTER RETIREMENT
PASTOR COOK. RIVER MULLINAX
SERVICING INTERIM PASTOR OF
SHILOH MISSIONARY BAPTIST
CHURCH IN SACRAMENTO FROM
NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE TO
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT. DECEMBER
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE RIVERTON
MULLINAX WAS CALLED IS THE
SENIOR PASTOR OF THE TWENTY
FOURTH STREET BAPTIST CHURCH
INVENTIVE IN THE MEADOW VIEW
AREA OF SACRAMENTO. WE
FAITHFULLY SERVE THEIR
SACRAMENTO COMMUNITY BEFORE
RETIRING IN DECEMBER TWO
THOUSAND AND SIX. RIVER MALL
ACCESS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE OF
FIFTY FIVE YEARS MC MULLEN ACTS
AS WELL AS THEIRSEVEN
CHILDREN. THERE TO THEIR
GRANDCHILDREN TEN GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN AND HIS TWO
SISTERS TODAY WE REMEMBER
PASTOR MULLINAX FIRST LOYAL
SERVICES TO OUR COMMUNITIES WE
SEND OUR DEEPEST CONDOLENCES TO
HIS FRIENDS AND FAMILY. PLEASE
JOIN ME RETURNING TODAY SESSION
IN HONOR OF PASTOR PAUL IN ACTS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
PAN CENTER LAMONT. GIVE A- THAT
ECONOMY. THANK YOU TODAY. TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF FORMER
SANTA BARBARA MAYOR HAL CONKLIN.
HOW CONKLIN PASSED AWAY LAST
MONTH AT THE AGE OF SEVENTY
FIVE. HE SERVED ON THE SANTA
BARBARA CITY COUNCIL FOR ALMOST
FIFTEEN YEARS FROM. NINETEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN TO NINETEEN
NINETY THREE AND BECAME MAYOR
IN NINETEEN NINETY THREE. HE IS
REMEMBERED NOT JUST AS A FORMER
MAYOR AND COUNCIL MEMBER BUT
ALSO AS AN ENVIRONMENTAL PART
PANEER AN ARTS ADVOCATE AND THE
CIVIC VISIONARY. HOW PLAYED A
SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN STARTING
THE COMMUNITY ENVIRONMENTAL
COUNCIL AFTER THE NINETEEN
SIXTY NINE OIL SPILL AND SERVED
AS ONE OF ITS FIRST DIRECTORS.
HIS ENVIRONMENTAL PASSIONATE
LEADERSHIP DID NOT END THERE
AND HE PLAYED A MAJOR ROLE IN
LAUNCHING THE CITY'S FIRST
RECYCLING PROGRAM. WELL ON THE
CITY COUNCIL HELD WAS A LEADER
IN REDEVELOPING AND SHAPING
SANTA BARBARA'S DOWNTOWN ARTS
AND CULTURAL DISTRICT. TODAY
PERCENT NOBLE CONTINUES TO BE A
PRIMARY DESTINATION FOR
TOURISTS. HIS PASSION FOR SANTA
BARBARA AND THE ARTS CONTINUED
EVEN LONG AFTER HIS DEPARTURE
FROM PUBLIC SERVICE. I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH HAL
THROUGH THE GRANADA THEATRE AND
SERVE ON THE COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT. COMMITTEE WITH HIM.
HE TOGETHER WE WORKED ON THAT
SCENE IN THE MINGLE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BRING SPANISH
SPEAKING AND LATIN AMERICAN
FOLKS TO THE GRANADA THEATRE.
HE WAS SUPPORTIVE HE WAS
VISIONARY AND HE WAS COMMITTED
TO DOING EVERYTHING WE COULD TO
EXPAND THE ARTS TO ALL
COMMUNITIES. ADDITIONALLY HE
SERVED AND WAS ONE INSTRUMENTAL
IN BRINGING COMMON TABLE TO
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY WE GOT
TOGETHER IN OUR COMMUNITY TO
BREAK BREAD. DURING THE COPA
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HE STARTED A
VIDEO SERIES THE SANTA BARBARA
LEADERSHIP TEAM WHICH CONVENE
BUSINESSES AND GOVERNMENT
LEADERS TO IDENTIFY WAYS TO
IMPROVE DOWNTOWN AND STATE
STREET. I GOT TO MEET WITH CAL
WITH HELL ON SEVERAL OCCASIONS
TO TALK ABOUT OUR WORK BOTH
LOCALLY AND AT THE STATE LEVEL
AND HOW WE COULD DO MORE FOR
SANTA BARBARA. HEALTH MEMORY
AND CONTRIBUTIONS TO SANTA
BARBARA WILL FOREVER BE
REMEMBERED. I WILL MISS A DEAR
FRIEND. I ASK THAT WE ADJOURNED
IN HIS MEMORY AND THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR LAMONT CENTRE
BRADFORD. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I TO RISE AND ARTISTS
THAT WE ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF MY
GOOD FRIEND AND FORMER
COLLEAGUE HAL CONKLIN I HAD THE
PLEASURE OF WORKING WITH MISTER
COCHRAN FOR TWELVE YEARS WITH
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON AND
HE WAS KNOWN AS MR. LOCAL
PUBLIC AFFAIRS HE WAS KNOWN AS
MR SANTA BARBARA AND IF THERE
WAS EVER AN INDIVIDUAL AT
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON THAT
WAS COMMITTED TO MAKING SURE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT WAS INVOLVED
IN THE PROCESS OF IMPROVING THE
UTILITIES IN THEIR COMMUNITY
WAS HAL AS STATED BY OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA BARBARA.
HE WAS A TRUE ENVIRONMENTALISTS
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY JUST A
PASSIONATE SERVANT. TO THE
PEOPLE OF NOT ONLY SANTA
BARBARA CALIFORNIA HE
REPRESENTED SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
WELL SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON
WALL AND HE WILL SURELY BE
MISSED SO I ASKED THAT WE
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF HAL
CONKLIN. THANK YOU SIR BRAD FOR
CENTERS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
HEARTFELT PRESENTATIONS IN YOUR
GERMAN MEMORY TODAY PLEASE
BRING THE NAMES FORWARD. SO
THEY CAN BE COMPLETELY-
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED BY THE
SENATE AND SHARE OUR
CONDOLENCES. WITH THE FAMILIES.
IF THERE IS NO OTHER BUSINESS
CLEAR MR PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO
MUCH COLLEAGUES THE NEXT FLOOR
SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR THIS
THURSDAY JUNE SEVENTEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AT NINE AM
THANK YOU. THANK YU SIR I CAN
THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL THREE THIRTY PM AT WHICH
TIME THE GERMAN MOTION WILL BE
PLACED WE WILL RECONVENE ON
THURSDAY AT NINE AM THANK YOU
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN.